and then he goes
do you have a punk
and i'm like what's a punk
and and he dropped three minutes on
crypto punks i had a run because the
family something and then that night
started a 45 to 75 hour journey over a
one week period where i consumed
everything about crypto punks and by
mid-january i decided that i was going
to buy a lot of them
you got your perspective
[Applause]
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
but what was it about crypto punks that
sort of made you want to be so obsessive
that you just jumped in at that point
because of what i was already doing i
had felt we were close to the time
you know my career winelibrary.com in 96
so you know what i did in social no 506
my career is what i'm doing right now
with vr i watch from very far away
and then when i think they're ready to
jump in
in a year in two years and 18 months and
nine months when it's on the pre-dawn of
the moment
that's when i jump
and i think that's what i'm good at so
you felt december last year was the
pre-dawn
yes i i felt that 2021 was going to be a
year and then you went all in
all in i have never seen any technology
so rapidly adopted
there's a reason
there's
money and greed involved
and that's
but don't you think it's
that might be one that's why it's
happening jody
but but that's but that's it
that's okay
if we collectively understand it
right we have to understand that there's
amazing things going on here but let
there be no confusion
ninety percent of the people currently
in our space are in the business of day
trading nfts to make a bag
and that's okay
but we have to understand it it's also
dangerous
we have to understand it this happened
with internet stocks in 95. this is what
happens
there was something called gold
that's what we did it's called the gold
rush like this happens
in the macro this is the most
interesting technology shift since the
internet decided to go social i think
there's been pent up demand rather
necessarily greed to actually own your
own content
and it may be it may be that your
friends
are the ones who are the day traders but
my friends
i i think there's a broader community
that actually wants to see something
about themselves
in their nfts or collections
a hundred percent that's why it's going
to be phenomenal it's creative it's
bringing a loss a lot of us back to
a creative place that we gave up at 7 9
12 13. there's incredible
nirvana
in this moment
what what the energy i'm bringing is
let's not be hypocrites
i'm sitting at dinners and meetings and
watching conversations and discords of
we're the anti-establishment word this
we're that
but then what they're really saying is
i'm gonna mint this and flip it
and so
what we have to be collectively aware of
is if we don't go through this moment
with eyes wide open
let me tell you how
this always plays out when we don't go
in with eyes wide open
it becomes over
saturated it becomes too the
conversation's around money
there's a lot of comment there's tons of
conversation around art there's even
more conversation around the money
and money scares me because people make
bad decisions yeah it scares me too and
p and i'm watching the thing i do for a
living is i watch
you know i talk a lot so i confuse
people because it always seems like i'm
talking because i talk a lot and i pump
out a lot of content but the reality is
90 of my day is watching
and i'm watching and people are
very clever and some people are not
clever but it all is going around the
same thing this reminds me of a lot of
web 2
on the great things take control of our
own all the stuff you know web 2 started
off very nirvana too you know like yeah
it but let there be but it didn't work
out that way of course it did i love how
everyone's like social media is so bad
i'm like you mean you liked the
alternative of mainstream media you mean
the media communication infrastructure
that led to the most fascism
dictatorship and wars let's not get
confused right now i understand the
current conversation is to razz social
but this concept that the media that
used to be controlled by 49 people was
so much better i think we're a little
bit
lacking thoughtfulness to the
conversation well let me put it
differently though which is
we have as consumers we have jumped on
many trends you know microcomputers
apple
various brands
mobile telephony nokia blackberry
and then more recently social networks
facebook twitter google
and every time as consumers we've jumped
in with both feet
someone else has ended up controlling
what we're doing
what what i what i love about where we
are now apart from the money-making part
it's not it's actually decentralized
it's not decentralized
i think it is no it's really not let's
talk about why
the technology's decentralized
is anybody watching what's going on
the humans become the centralization
but that moves because the
centralization is moving because the
technology allows the centralization to
move until we take accountability for
our old actions
we will blame platforms and people
guys
gals this is an important conversation
everyone's like this is awesome it's
decentralization i spent 13 hours
discovering an artist named sarah in
texas that i like and just literally say
oh i like this art and then i get 400 dm
saying you're the centralization now you
[ __ ]
okay then i like what like this thought
the biggest issue
that leads to unhappiness and anxiety in
society
is the decision that somebody else
controls you
like what are you gonna blame
when it becomes decentralized
other humans
something else like what are you gonna
blame
like
it's fascinating like you know there you
were there social was competing against
rupert murdoch and two other people and
read like three old white dudes that
controlled all our thoughts
social
now it's like this [ __ ] algorithm
makes me a racist [ __ ] you
you're a racist
facebook made zero people racist
facebook exposed the racists
so
i'm not confused what the current
conversation is i'm very happy that
everyone's excited to blame twitter and
facebook and i'll be here in 10 years
sitting here and you'll be blaming
centralization allowed humans to have
too much control
because they're blaming elon jody
again they're blaming elon
no no one would blame me of course
they're blaming elon
pumped it up
guys you know what's decentralized when
you have enough self-esteem to think for
yourself
that's decentralized
this is going to play out very very
simply it's going to become
decentralized technology there's going
to be governments are going to fight for
centralization i don't know how i think
you've sort of manipulated the argument
i think i think where we were going was
the value creation in social networks is
centralized and they value creation
in the nft space it's decentralized it
just wasn't this thought that facebook
inc and twitter and everybody else got
all the value what about the 8 trillion
[ __ ] influencers that had no audience
that paid nothing to get attention in
return and make millions and millions of
dollars
what about that jody
like this thought that they kept all the
economic like it's absurd
it's real like oh you're talking about
the influences on social who make money
out of having lots of followers
you mean the people that paid nothing
for the attention in a world where you
pay for attention yes i'm talking about
that um
it's a it's a very important
conversation it's a reasonable
conversation right because pre-social
media if you wanted attention i did this
for my dad's business i had to pay 80
000 to a newspaper to get a full-page ad
then i just made a youtube video like
there's a trade there but don't don't
you think one of the craziest things in
the history of marketing
is that cmos of brands
paid to have people follow their
facebook page and then they paid
facebook cmo of brands
of big companies don't know
what's going on in the reality of the
current marketplace
but i think the cmo brands now have an
opportunity to have their own nft
marketplaces with their own fans
as they should and i'm i can't wait for
it on their own platforms not you not
deep inside facebook websites i can't
wait
i'm here for it
i love your work i love you too like i'm
here for it but i
i think the energy i'm bringing this
morning
is let's have 360 conversations
like 360 conversations are healthy
like like pay attention to what's hap
everyone here's a good one in nft land
the community's going to drive it
let's talk about that
this is the community by the way this is
a great community let's talk about
what's happening in our space let's go
into the details
gary this project you know this
porcupine with [ __ ] a clown knows
right
this project's gonna work
not because the founders but because the
communities so i sit and think about
that right so
jody do you have any bulls chicago bulls
fans there were in my new jersey high
school in 1992
sega
how many i know you're an aussie how
many i'm not um
i told you i was in here for 40 seconds
joey listen
how many chicago bulls fans were in my
new jersey high school in 1992. tell me
half the [ __ ] school wow because
michael jordan was doing his thing and
everybody in the community was wearing
bull swag
how many bulls fans are in my high
school in new jersey right now jody
zero
the community
is all for it
because
their money's tied up in it
but if the founders of the project can't
navigate it to success
the fans aren't going to show up to the
stadium
we have to be very thoughtful about this
there's just a lot of things happen
listen jody you were there in 0.50607
when i was coming up yeah we both joined
twitter the same that's right yeah you
were you recall like that
there was all those combos and i think
the reason i get to be here today
is because i've navigated those 15 years
a specific way
and for me
when i sit my obligation
when i do an interview like this is i'm
going to give everybody here my best
stuff
they're going to do whatever they can do
with it i could be wrong i've been wrong
before i could be right
but what i what i'm watching is what i
saw in 06 and 07 which is the
conversation's one-dimensional
and if you peel the layer off
an unfortunate amount of it is really
about short-term economics
and i think that for us to achieve what
we all probably subconsciously and
consciously want we need to level up the
convo of what's happening here and
there's a lot happening here and a lot
of good
but we also have to watch out for some
of the things that are brewing so just
zooming out to 35 000 feet
what industries do you think are going
to be disrupted by nfts over the next 12
months over the next 12 months
i mean
to be frank i don't really think about
it in that terms i'll tell you why if
you asked me that question in 1995 about
the internet i wouldn't have known that
jeff bezos talent was going to be
deployed against bookstores
i wouldn't have known that right i
wouldn't have known that some guy
whose wife was a pez collector was going
to build ebay
but i knew in 1995 if i was sitting here
as a 20 year old i would have said all
of them
and that's what i felt about social and
that's what i know is happening right
here right now every business is gonna
be affected by what we're talking about
right now i just don't know
what gal in tennessee has an idea right
now and is gonna start something that's
gonna go after this or what what person
in you know harlem is going to go after
transportation but what i can tell you
is there won't be an industry not
addressed affected changed impacted by
the infrastructure of decentralized
servers with a platform whether it's
whether it's seoul or cardona or or you
know or eth with apps being built on top
of it at scale it's gonna [ __ ] change
the world and it's gonna change in a big
[ __ ] way
[Applause]
well
i'd like to say thank you to you on
behalf of the community because
many people say to me from outside this
community why have nfts been so
successful
and i say three things to them
one
one of the smartest marketing
programs campaigns i've ever seen
for 69 million dollars
everyone in the world was talking about
the sale of the people
artwork that was amazing that's one
moment that's one
people staying at home using clubhouse
because clubhouse was
and not in this order by the way and
then the last thing is you because you
have done so much for this community in
in being so passionate about it so big
thank you
it's very nice
everybody it's it's really why i want to
talk you know it's funny i'm an
entrepreneur i'm a businessman i want to
go to garage sale buy something for a
dollar for five dollars it doesn't mean
i don't understand what's happening in
the macro that i want everybody to be
more thoughtful about and more
importantly the thing we have to watch
out for is the hypocrisy
like if the the bigger danger is the way
we're talking about it but then really
it's about can i flip this for 5x right
like we have to be very conscious about
this because
here's what's likely going to happen if
we stay this way if we stay this way
then what's going to really happen is
we're going to have a massive crash
because there's too much supply
the man won't catch up
people are moving around communities i'm
incredibly worried about people betting
money they can't afford
you know if you look at wall street
when people bet money they can't afford
and they lose it all it leads to suicide
is our space ready for somebody to
commit suicide because they got a rug
pull
right like there's a lot here see i'm
really surprised how much you're
focusing on the flipping part because i
see so many people in the broader
community
who you know they want to have a crypto
punk because they might think it looks
like them or their wife or someone we
have someone talking later today about
that and it's tribal it's tribal i don't
think it's just about the flipping
listen i appreciate that and again i you
know what i'm trying to do here in the
limited time is bring a conversation to
the forefront that i think can add
because i'm buying everything that i
think we're all buying there's so much
you know there's so much excitement
i i don't think that many people are
buying a five hundred thousand dollar
crypto punk because it looks like them
well wait till you're here who said that
wait till you hear the who there's
someone talking today about why they did
that but i mean do you know what i mean
like i think people well but crypto punk
was a placeholder for art you know for
things for collections look this has
been the greatest thing that has
happened to the independent artist in a
long time and i'm [ __ ] here for it
because i love all of you
oh man i'm in one two
there is
just the thing i loved about 06 209 the
friendships that you're all about to
make with each other like please please
please please whenever there's i don't
know what the programming looks like
here but if you go out for a few minutes
please some people are more introverted
i get that but for people that are a
little bit more introverted things that
nature this is exactly the
community at this moment where everybody
is as excited for you to come and say
hello to them as they are to you this is
literally your best friend your business
partner somebody you might marry is
literally sitting in here right now
and i know this because i saw it in the
last two waves please push yourself to
say hello to a stranger when you guys
have breaks
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times
i also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon